hello everyone and welcome to what is
definitely one of the weirder games I've
played in over the board tournament
it's from the tournament I played for
the past three days you guys said that
you would enjoy a few more games so this
is a game from the last day if you
remember I said I have three more games
to play from the penultimate round and
I'm facing Marco Jovic strong feeling
master who I faced before and he's
beaten me every time yeah I I did win
some of the games but when he was
younger then when he got stronger he
always always defeated me and well he
just uh he's just a very strong
aggressive attacking player so I
prepared the Scandinavian defense and
not for him I prepared it for it for
another video master although he he
played d4 so I didn't get to use my
secret Scandinavian weapon although that
game ended in a draw so III didn't mind
but I did get to use sort of use my
preparation here it wasn't a big
preparation it was a you know a few
moves of the opening but still it was a
it's a it's a very interesting game so
without further ado let's check it out
he played efore I prepared d5 so I
played e5 the Scandinavian defense with
each capture establish Queen captures
and now Knight to c3 and now although
there are quite quite a few retreats
possible
lately I've been using the Queen to d6
line and if you've seen for example the
world rapid embolus championship Magnus
has been using this against everyone so
he continued with the d4 I play Knight
to f6
we have Knight to f3 and I went for a 6
here you can choose a few of a few
different approaches I prefer the a6 one
as I tried the the the fiend carrying
the bishop and those games didn't really
work out all that great so he continues
with the g3 seems very natural the
bishop is coming to g2 you're supporting
idea for square you want the bishop to
come to effort to attack the Queen so
very rapid natural development for white
I continue - up to g4 - up to g2 and now
Knight to c6 and this is one of the
reasons I I started using this
Scandinavian defense it's just very
natural moves you move the Queen you
get the Knights into the game you you
develop the bishop spinning the night
you're gonna Castle queenside so it
might be a bit dangerous White has a lot
of attacking options but then then again
I mean what isn't he continue with
Bishop to f4 and now although you could
go for some Queen to east sex ideas I
decided to go Queen to b4 I saw that not
in this line in particular but I saw
that Queen to b4 can be played and it's
it shouldn't be an issue for black and
here he decided to castle of course he's
not worried about me capturing on b2 as
obviously I am castling queenside it
will take me a few more moves to Castle
kingside so chances are on castling
queenside and he would well definitely
welcome the semi open B file for his
rook so I hear he just decided to castle
capturing and c7 maybe can be played
it's it does stop me from castling
queenside but the problem is he's
keeping his King in the center a bit too
much and here after rook c8 and he
brings the bishop back now I capture on
b2 and now it could be dangerous with
the King still in the center of the
board the knife is under attack
after the knight moves I can go he five
and well here just everything everything
is hanging I don't know what what's
happening here it's complete craziness
but he decides against it he decides for
castles and now he asks me do I want a
capture on b2 which is definitely a bad
decision if you capture on between out
that the King castled for Queen d2 now
prepares to bring the rook to attack the
Queen and well doesn't really matter
what I play for example if I Castle
queenside which I definitely want to do
then you really run into trouble just
rook a2 b1 also can be played Queen a3
and now you can even play rook captures
on b7 so capturing Queen side would no
longer be an option here for example if
you capture ninety five comes with a
double attack here so you're winning
back material and well you also get our
finishing attack and if if black tries
to defend with something like this and
then just rook the b1 check King to see
it and now nice to see for traps the
Queen so a lot of very interesting ideas
here
if you capture the b2 points so of
course I decided against that
I just Castle queenside and here there
are a few options he can choose here he
decided to go for d5 it is the most
aggressive option another ideas now that
the d4 pawn is under pressure from the
the rook and the knight is the either
challenge the bishop would h3 which can
be played but that that loses a pawn for
example rook captures and before Queen
has to move and now you move the bishop
bishop to h5 and still it's it's just a
clean point of for blacks so instead of
this d5 move you could also play Knight
to e2 now the Knights control the d4
pawn nicely c3 can be played you're not
worried about this since you get a nice
open assembly often befall for the rook
so this is possible however he decided
for d5 and I thought that this was a bad
move at the moment I was playing the
game I thought that's too early I mean I
have a rook on the D file and the queen
is here although this move is perfectly
fine and it has been played before by
grandmasters so it's not a problem but I
actually thought that this was really
bad for him and I played a 5 + e5 III
play d5 and I left left the board I was
you know just throwing around chicken
got some other games and I really I
didn't calculate anything I just I just
didn't see a good move for him so now I
I thought that if I was really just an
excellent move as I like for example in
the Sicilian if you manage to get d5 in
you will be a very happy person similar
in this variation if you get can get be
5 in the free up your dark square Bishop
and to counter the effects of this d5
push also you you claim the d4 square
for your knight so that's excellent I
just thought that there was no good move
for him to play here there is a good
move for him to play here and we're
gonna come back to this but feel free to
pause the video what would you play here
it's just just a very interesting
position so I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to find a useful move here
congratulations as it is a very
complicated position because
neither my opponent nor myself have even
even considered this move I believe I
don't know if he considered it he just
didn't play it but its first we're gonna
check out a few interesting lines for
example if you move the bush Bishop to
g5 it is possible then I get to the d4
square for my knight and also now I get
to exploit this pin one once he and pins
let's say something like Queen to d3 now
you can go back Bishop to f5 and you
have a nice double attack on the c2
point so not not really something you
want to try with white another thing
after this if I've move you can go back
Bishop to d2 now threaten some nasty
discoveries with your knight
however then efore is is the idea and
this is the problem every time the
bishop moves
efore comes and it's it's a very
unpleasant now you have to give up a
piece here you will win back your piece
it's not a problem but after Queen
captures D captors here Queen
characteris it's just much it's just a
better position for black and it's
easier to play it you already have a
rope here this bishop looks so it looks
really odd so even if I don't know it's
just hard to play and there are some
forcing lines like h3 Bishop captures
Bishop captures and the rook captures
and b2 which just transpose into a not
transpose but they trade down into a
better endgame for black for example
Bishop captures here you're gonna
capture here you're gonna grab this with
check so you don't lose it for nothing
Roque characters here and black would
have two pieces for a rook of course
this is much better for black so these
are some of the options that are
possible but there is one move that is
best here and it's considered theory of
this opening it's a three here so if any
of you consider a three here that's just
amazing because a three really poses
problems for black and a three is one of
the reasons why a six is considered to
be better than a five but that's uh I
will also mention that here the problem
is the Queen loses control of the fourth
rank for example if you try Queen c4
then white gets to unpin for example
Knight to e2 and now okay you can trade
but then your queen is under attack as
well and you don't want to release this
white from this pin
another thing after a3 is you can go
back you can go Queen to b6 but then you
the bishop to get away from harm's way
with an attack on the Queen Bishop to e3
you just attack the Queen and if Knights
the d4 you can just capture it Bishop
captures it captures and now you can go
Queen captures Queen captures and now
Knight captures on d4 and white white
will be very happy here so after a three
it's not easy for black to find a move
you have to go for Queen captures on b2
if you are to to remain sort of sort of
better because now after Queen to d3
preparing rook rooks to be one now you
can go
efore and now it's it's extremely
complicated a queen to c4 comes rook
captures on d5 happens now Knight
captures on e4
you will play Bishop to e6 just
threatening some very nasty discoveries
and now Queen back to e to and after the
trade here knife captures Queen captures
you will go Bishop to d6 continue
development and the game continues so
this is one of the things that can
happen had he played a three but it's
just just crazy stuff I mean in in such
a position a3 but it is a normal move
consider theory and has been played in
Grandmaster games now but I will mention
y-ye six is considered better it's
considered better because well you now
actually have a threat here all the
other lines are really just a tree for
Singh you to capture on b2 here if you
try the same idea let's say you try a
three now it's no longer possible
because of the threat on d5 now Queen
captures here Queen d3 isn't good for
white because now you can just capture
on d5 and there is no going after the
Queen because well there's just the
Queen captures on c3 but okay
even in Grandmaster games no one plays
d6 everyone plays d5 it's just that I
guess those who prepare the Scandinavian
prefer it which of course I knew nothing
about at the moment when I was playing
the game but my opponent didn't play any
of the moves that we discussed he didn't
play Bishop g5 he didn't play Bishop d2
he didn't play a three he played a most
daring move he played d captures on c6
and it is definitely a new move in the
position and when I saw this I was like
oh come on
again I thought that I wondered
something terrible that this is actually
possible and that there was no way for
me to get out but okay I mean before I
started calculating I of course accepted
the Queen sacrifice because I first have
to see which rook grabs and II wanted to
start my process of calculating of
course I had to take the Queen if I
didn't take the Queen then I'm just a
non-material so he played rook F capture
son d1 and now I went into a think some
twenty minutes I believe it was which is
which is quite a lot as it's a 45-minute
game but feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out what you would
play here as as black while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it the correct move
is just pawn characters on f4 and it's
it took me a while because I really had
to make sure that you know this this was
not winning for white and I did
calculate a lot of things here
I tried Bishop to d6 to see if this
works I tried to see if efore works I
tried to see to check out a lot of ideas
but all of them work in white favor for
example there should be six you can just
capture on e5 if Bishop captures you
have Knight captures and now you have a
lot of problems here if you capture for
example here you get seek after Sun b7
with check and now it's it's not good if
you capture and it's not good if you
don't capture so for example King b8 and
just nicely six check picks up the Queen
one of the one of the reasons why Bishop
to d6 is not possible but of course I
wanted to start developing my pieces I
did consider efore but II for I
considered a three on e4 and I saw that
there really was no good square for the
Queen I don't want to open up the
position to allow captures and rook to
be one and if if I move then nice to see
five becomes possible and it's just hard
to evaluate this position it was almost
impossible to evaluate this position but
even if you continue Bishop captures and
d1 rook captures on d1 Bishop to c5 you
go after the F to pawn white again has
this Bishop to h3 which is really really
crazy you go back with the King night
capture assignee for defense f2 and
again you cannot capture because of
Knight to d7 check picking up the Queen
and there are so many lines in in which
he wins the Queen wins the Queen back so
after this rook captures on f1 I also
thought about this but of course I
immediately decided that this was not
good look a b-1 goes after the Queen
Queen a3 now you capture with check King
moves you deliver check King moves and
this is now mate so definitely not
possible so after considering the
position I played it captures on f4 and
I found a refutation that that was
really not all that difficult to find
but you know when you're playing over
the board and you know you already
wasted 20 minutes you have to make sure
you didn't miss anything so
congratulations to everyone who decided
to capture the bishop but see capture
some bees 70s would he play and now I
played Queen captures it doesn't matter
that I'm going under diagonal of the
bishop because after a five I just
played f3 and now his Bishop is out of
the game but he he still decided to make
things very interesting he played Knight
captures an f7 point being that if I
continue with captures here then it's
just mate in one
Rudy 8 is mate so I decided for Bishop
to c5 instead to give up my rook for a
very quick maneuver he decided to
capture on a trade I played Bishop
captures on f2
King captures on f2 so because I wanted
all of the captures to come with tempo
so Queen b6 check and now he can't go to
a to a dark square because the dis runs
into mate Queen e3 checking if one and
now Knights the e4 threatening mate
which he cannot defend and if he
captures them into this mate check a
king moves and mate so after this King
to f1 after this Queen b6 check he
played sorry King to f1 and now
everything comes with check just
captures with check he captured I
captured the rook he captured back and
now I just captured here and now I'm off
to much material he continued with 92 I
played captures he moved the rook again
attack that forcing the king to defend
both pieces so he played King f1 and now
I play Knight to g4 and here they're
really
no good defense he cannot move the night
because of this mate
he played night of seven I played Queen
III and it was in this position that he
resigned in the game as I'm threatening
mate on f2 and there's nothing you can
do to to avoid this so it's a really
really weird game but you know it's it's
such a position where you think that
nothing nothing works but it's actually
has been played before and it's
considered standard Theory after D v e5
and now if you ever find yourself in
this position if you play against the
Scandinavian or or enjoy playing the
Scandinavian then always be aware of a
three yeah now I don't know if my
opponent found a three I don't think he
would go for D captures in c6
I think he went for it because he just
didn't like any any of the continuations
that arise after we actually moved the
bishop so I think he started he started
this and he he decided maybe captures on
a four wasn't possible for black but in
the end it was but yeah if a three is
played here it's just a perfectly normal
position that has been played before and
white white continues with with the edge
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it last day out of three
possible points I want two points I I
won one game in route 2 and in the end I
had five and a half points out of nine
in the end I clinched sixth place which
is a lot better than I then I thought I
did do since I really don't have a lot
of playing experience I play very rarely
these days and well most of my opponents
were higher rated than me six of my
opponents were higher rated than me and
I you know I I did fairly well I lost
the two games I lost were against the
Mattia I showed you that game he won the
tournament and the one the second one I
lost against you're killing me hell he
defeated me with the black piece in his
defense I really played too aggressive
in that game and well I definitely
deserved to lose but yeah those were the
two games that I lost and I'm sorry
about that I just had a podcast with
with Ben Johnson for four over and over
an hour and I was really talking a lot
for the
our so it really feels yeah in my voice
but yeah and I will also share your link
to that it comes out next Tuesday so you
know hope you you will enjoy that as
well but yeah I'm really really happy
with how I played the tournament could
have been better but if I played any
better it would have been too good so
I'm very happy as it is but yeah really
a weird game and well like I said mark
always beats me
so very very weird that I was able to
clinch a win like this in in the
Scandinavian so you know maybe it will
inspire some of you to try the
Scandinavian as it offers a lot of play
for black as you can see and you know if
white doesn't know a threes is a great
option here you know you he can have a
lot of problems here so the once again I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank a Pablo Mohan Eduardo Maeda
RJ Kapoor a John Deere law office and
Hisham all for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
whatever content I come up until I start
the Paul Morphy saga so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and do join the leaches
team battle the links are in the
description below see you soon